when you're in it when i was watching
you you were doing a breathing exercise
right before you were you were breathing
and then they put the bubble you know
the water coming up below you and then
you put the thing on your nose and you
went in what what's the exercise you're
doing right before what is that exercise
okay i will tell you ninety percent of
my
i will keep it for myself ten percent is
it is it fair for you yes it's okay
yeah yeah because there is a lot of guy
who are better than me
who are more most famous than me
and they were trying in the last two
years to break my record
uh which was 24-11
and they didn't succeed so i have
special
preparing if you know what i mean i
found myself
in some kind of i'm not doing uh
meditation
i'm not doing yoga it's just my
let's say strong will and i found myself
okay five breed one easier
five deep breed one easier five
i don't want to say how many of them i
i did it and then i said okay
now it's time uh dead or alive
uh it was earthquake during my attempt
small
but it was earthquake
and i said to my coach i'll kill you
if you take me out why i will
i will explain why because the people
in that area are suffering
for 10 15 20
35 earthquakes a day
it's just this one earthquake during my
attempt
if you're taking me out trust me look at
me in the eyes i will kill you
because i have no i have no
uh i can't
do to those people they are waiting
outside for me
to break guinness record only if there
is no water because
everything's crushed then say okay
buddha go out because there is no water
around you
but otherwise and it was small i can
feel it
i was feeling and i said like this no no
no no
way don't don't get me out so
the the most important thing i have
the biggest uh uh
wish to make that kind of
that kind of guinness record because
i i'm always thinking about the kids
not about myself i'm just their voice
if you know what i mean i can't help
them on the other way
if you know what i mean so if i make
24 uh 37 and it's going to be
guinness look at this
i am in front of you you are you you are
legend
and how how i get to you if i
didn't do guinness record
am i right now it gives me uh
a possibility to say uh
autistic kids are not it's not illness
it's just matter of state
if you know what i mean they are not
evil
if they are uh shaking their self
don't look at like them like they are
some kind of disease uh turn around your
head
please try to help them because they are
not doing in purpose
it's just the brain if you know what i
mean and it's not
it's not curable it's a state for the
rest of their life
and on us it's a matter of how
we can make the life easier
that's the main point and and
at the end of the my life you have a
mirror
and you're gonna say i get my best there
is a
beautiful sentence it's my favorite
sentence
in a movie resting uh
private uh right right having private
ryan yes
saving prior time sorry sorry and
the last scene the last scene tom hanks
said to matt damon do you remember yeah
last sentence
make it count make it count or something
uh
deserve it deserve it yeah and he asked
his wife at the end of the movie
and that's right this is the the whole
point of my life deserve it
i i i'm always you know like this
it sorry it makes me cry
but this is my motto deserve it
you came to this earth you you don't
have to be tesla
you don't have to be armstrong on a moon
you don't have to be uh musk you don't
have to be
the last president before uh
obama now this one uh obama you don't
have to be obama
which i'm not approved for his uh
awareness for a piece i think
other guys deserve it more than him
because
uh i expected much i'm his friend don't
get me wrong
don't get me wrong i expected much more
from him
he's still my favorite president
but i'm kind of kind of disappointed
because he has
such a great opportunity to make the
world
better i thought for sure you would have
said trump is your favorite
for sure i thought you loved donald
trump no
way no way are you kidding me
i'm kidding we of course i'm kidding i
know your
story because no no i don't want to say
any
any wrong word about the trump because
he he was your president
and you have to respect that yes there
is 300 million
people in waters in america am i right
and if you take 72 millions of people
you have to respect them on this on the
other way
72 millions croatia has only four
come on 72 millions they say we want
trump for a president
and you have to respect them you can't
say they're all stupid
don't get me wrong it's my opinion it's
my opinion
i i don't uh agree with my ex-president
in croatia but i say okay
he's my president and i have to
follow their rules if you know what i
mean i was
you know i i elected i was
i never i never miss any kind of
election
i always go because i think it's your
duty to make a cross for
one person or the other it's your duty
and it has to be obligation so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
you